so it will be about the volume of a
normal incoming phone call it'll be a
siren-like sound and it will last for 10
seconds and there'll be a message saying
this is the government's Nationwide test
alert system you don't need to do
anything it's a bit like if you receive
any kind of other Alert on your phone
now you may subsequently want to dismiss
it but you don't have to do anything at
the moment you receive it and whilst
this is a test in future this could be
the sound that saves your life so
there's there's two ways of disabling
this now I wouldn't advise people to do
it but if they they feel they they need
to first of all you can turn your phone
off and in those circumstances you won't
receive the alert or you can go into
your settings search emergency alerts
and turn it off that way